foreign
Montana hey Mike how are you
I'm doing well how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up good uh well my
wife and I have been in babysit 3B for
about 30 months now and we are wondering
uh we're getting a little too long and
we should start moving things around or
what
um we're in an area where we think that
we can find a house for 180
uh it's a sale price
um
and
my take-home pay is such that 25 would
make us have a 51 000 down payment
uh but if we cheated that 25 up to 30
percent we would only need 28 which is
about what we would have by the summer
so I'm wondering if that's something
that is
acceptable or if I'm if I if we should
just go take a cold shower or something
no
okay let's pan back for a second and say
okay why do we have a ratio on the size
of house payment
not not how not how much can I get away
with why do we why do we teach you that
well we teach you that because if your
house payment is too freaking big
as a percentage of your income you can't
breathe
you have no margin and then everything
other than the house becomes a crisis
because the house is pinching you and
that's what we in our business call
house poor now you know all that right
Mike
yes sir okay and so to the extent you go
over 25 percent you start moving in that
direction
but I've had people call here with a
house payment that's 50 of their
take-home pay and no kidding they can't
breathe they've got to sell that house
if they can't double their income pretty
quick so if you want to quote unquote
cheat yourself because there's no one
else in this discussion but you and your
wife and your kids right you treat
yourself in your future up on the 30
side because you got a little bit of
house fever what's the trade-off under
what circumstances would that be wise or
less wise okay uh if if your company is
announcing that it's probably going to
have layoffs this summer well that would
be totally stupid then
okay if you're in a job where your
income's probably going to go up 30
percent in the next two years
then pretty quickly your house payment
is going to be 25 percent of your
take-home pay if you're going to uh buy
this house at 30 of your income and then
have the third baby and your wife says
she wants to be home and now it's 48 of
your take-home pay well that's obviously
not going to work so it kind of has to
do with future plans right
so how stable is your income what do you
mean what do you do
uh well I'm actually switching into a
job in order to calculate uh switching
into Tech from being a trucker
um so that's
uh paying for school for that is part of
why it's taking us you know the 30
months and three baby step 3B okay when
will you when will you be making the
switch
uh that'll be end of next summer August
September somewhere in there
um and we're we're basing these numbers
on what I'm estimating that to be uh my
wife is planning on coming home she's
currently working as a nurse she's
planning on coming home when we have her
third child in May whoa I got like whoa
that
like I've done this before or something
okay yes exactly I was thinking the same
thing all right and so yeah so you know
when the Smoke Clears you're at 30 in a
new career
correct yep um and until the Smoke
Clears you're better than 30 percent
because your trucker plus her income
before the third kid comes in before you
switch no no no the the 30 will be based
on just my income
um after I switch jobs yeah that's why I
said When the Smoke Clears and she quits
oh yeah yeah and she quits yeah so but
it should be more it should be less than
30 with both of you working in the
meantime right
oh oh yeah yeah it'll be okay I do I
don't have those numbers but yeah yeah
and then what do you think the
trajectory is on your income after you
get the new job um
the information I have says that it'll
go up quite a bit
um okay then you're not going to be 30
for very long
okay so what we're looking at here is we
want to look at the film strip not the
snapshot
okay the film strip is your whole life
all the way out are we are we strapping
ourselves to a house long term and what
you're doing is you're going in and out
start with you're going to be below then
you're going to be up to 30. and then
you're going but 30 is just passing
through because then four months into
the new job you get another raise right
or whatever eight percent whatever that
kind of thing so you may have one year
of tight
but it's not but your plan is not to
live a life of being home house poor
then that starts to be more wise than I
work for the state I get a three percent
raise every year and my wife's gonna
quit in two years and then we're really
going to be screwed no we're not signing
up for that one
right okay you see the difference
I do see the difference yes sir yeah so
that so Dave this makes me nervous okay
because I maybe it's my years of working
with young professionals but
I can't think of a group that
overestimates what they're going to be
making in 18 months and then make
current fiscal decisions based on this
imaginary growth that may or may not
come that makes sense yeah so here's the
thing here's what you might be facing
what John's pointing out if this doesn't
go the way you think you may be faced
with your wife keeps working or you have
to sell the house
or if you had if you had to stay a
trucker in three years could you make
this house payment
no
um yeah no not without going over the
road which is something not with her
coming home yeah yeah so you may end up
trading her being home for this house if
the career path doesn't work out like
you're playing so you have to go all in
on the career plan right yeah you got to
make this thing work yeah yeah and or
you go hey it's just a house we give it
a shot and it's more important that we
move to a smaller house it's more
important than she stays home that's
right and that's what that's more
important to us than that particular
house yeah and you just sell the house
also you can refinance the house when
interest rates come down
that'll help